I bump into you every now and then and I
see your family you with your family and
you seem like a great mom you seem like
you really do how old your kids
thank you Conant my daughter Stella's 13
and my son Nolan is 11 and I do have
folks just like the age of my kids
you're 13
okay I can realize they were the exact
same exact same your daughter's 13 just
like my 13 yeah and they're both
redheads - no she's not oh my god was
not a retino neither my kids my kids
have are like white white blond hair
yeah it's creepy I don't know what
happened there
but but yeah so and yes so I am fun and
a lot of times we I like to play games
my dad raised me and he was really silly
and fun and always into mischief so we
play truth or dare a lot like a lot of
times when I'm like my son and did
Planet Brava this summer and I was
picking him up a camp after camp he and
his friend Jesse and his friend Cooper
and we went to a California Pizza
Kitchen and I was like you guys want to
play truth or dare and so it was like
five o'clock in the afternoon and so
they gave me a dare and they were like I
dare you to go up to that table those
two people sitting there and walk up to
them and I was like okay and they made
me say go up to them and say hi um I
don't know if you know this but nine I
had to walk up to their table and go hi
I don't know if you know this but my
name is Molly Shannon and I'm a
[Applause]
so you see I'm guessing you did it right
I did it I did it the restaurant wasn't
that crowd and I was like this is so
dorky and I'm so embarrassed but I did
it good for you no good for you I think
it's good for kids to see you do that is
good and then they like to do Darrin's
up but it was very silly and it just
makes me laugh and it's entertaining you
have you ever played truth or dare with
adults if you got an adult yes yes on
Saturday Night Live years ago Alec
Baldwin was the host and we were out for
a cast dinner and it was my idea I was
like let's play truth or dare and I
dared Alec took you on rip his shirt
open to show his sexy hairy chest and
walk back into the kitchen and ask this
that cooks do you have any more red hot
pepper yeah he loved it he'll do
anything yeah the thing is he does so
many things like that people don't even
notice now like well take care of you
mr. Baldwin all right
you